this video is brought to you by
manscape.com
the holidays are coming up and as guys
you know how hard it is to buy
men gifts luckily manskit has the gifts
that keep on giving if you know what i'm
talking about
we're talking about the manscape
performance package an all-in-one
grooming kit
from head to toe all-in-one man
maintenance
get rid of nose and eerie hairs
especially for old asian men like me
with the weed whacker baby baby it's a
trimmer designed for those
small holes kind of like my butthole
yeah
trim below the waist with the lawnmower
3.0
works above the waist too if you're that
hairy i used it for my nipples
with skin safe technology now i can
confidently trim the area around my ball
sacks
with this light too isn't it cool yeah
you also get ball deodorant and ball
toner to keep your sensitive areas fresh
after grooming
manscape is having a black friday and a
cyber monday sale
for some of their biggest savings ever
so
don't wait to get their performance
package and don't forget to use our link
www.massgate.com
jknews to get an additional 20 off
plus free international shipping the
link will be in the description box
below
your balls will thank you very much
[Music]
okay guys this one's kind of cool really
kind of
cute cute kind of cute cuny
oh okay um so this guy's
house was burning down it's a really
cool story wow
so cute
his name is anton anton nguyen
oh and hey my people yep oh is it the
parrot
yes oh i know this is vietnamese
his parrot saved his life by being like
anton anton anton
oh i thought it was the fire alarm
himself oh they had
he had smoke detectors but the parrot
beat him to the
beat the smoke detectors and so they
were able to escape
and it was like his entire house erupted
in flames
so he kind of needed that head start i
hate to be the cynical
what was the pair just trying to save
his own ass probably
oh definitely but also he the pair could
have ran out oh really
or something oh i guess you need to open
this okay
come on i don't know if he was in a cage
kfc you don't know how to own a pair one
of those free range parrots
yeah pfc pfc or pf kfp
kfc yeah this was at kangaroo point
this was at kangaroo point kangaroo
point yeah
it's a real animal ass place yeah i wish
that was my address it happened in
australia
did you know that there's like three
states in america where you can own a
kangaroo
texas yeah it's very specific is texas
one of them
uh i don't remember i remember like
michigan's one or something but
why florida probably it's like yeah but
you but you wouldn't know this normally
and so i was like whoa
i don't think it's weird that certain
states ban very specific animals
yeah so i know like someone who owns a
hedgehog but they have to go to las
vegas
because it's illegal in california you
could marry a your sister in alabama
i was googling it i was googling it and
then i don't even have a sister but i
was just i was curious
then i found out alabama you can i
already knew that
i think you need a vpn
i've said this before i'll say it again
my sister's hot as [ __ ] and that's why i
got her
a hedgehog for her birthday oh my god we
had to drive to vegas for it
you've got your sister a hedgehog
because she's hot as [ __ ] she's so
[ __ ] hot that i was like how do i get
this pissed off people don't know the
reference so they don't know
no my sister's hot okay so i have to
[ __ ] try to give her cool gifts so
that she understands that like i'm
serious about this whole thing yes
yeah wait how come hedgehogs are
executed can you tell me later with this
that's a rare gift it's just funny every
time he says it
is funny because he doesn't think the
sister is hot but nobody knows what his
sister looks like wait
hey blades so so when you're dealing
with the chick who's like a 10 out of
10.
you gotta i don't know what happened but
like my hearing started going out when
you said that i was like
no blades you have to break the norms in
order to reach
somebody who's that [ __ ] hot and so
you have to drive to vegas to pick up
something out of an exotic
he's sipping for his sister yeah they're
used for these two every guy falling
over themselves and i'm like why i'm
your brother how do i compete with this
[ __ ]
that's true that's true
okay did the charm let's just say it in
the charm okay
i'm so glad i don't have like a hot
sister
i don't know what i do [ __ ] nothing
is what you would do you would do
nothing if you had hot stay away from
alabama because you could really do
something no right
damn that's dangerous are there other
states because i i don't know that's the
only one that popped up when i googled
it
wait but what made you google that yeah
um i think i was thinking about like
i was thinking you had a sister no i'm
just thinking about our country in our
country
it's although it seems like it's like uh
in on crazy unrest right now i'm like
what other place can you have
like 50 different crazy ideas and you
can
align yourself with the place that you
can find this
you could be a safe haven in right like
you you can go to a place where you can
do heroin you can
have same-sex marriage you're like you
know what unifies all of us
we all like our sister no no no no i was
like oh but what if you're like really
crazy and you want to marry your sister
i was like
is there a estate for you and i'm like
alabama so here's what drives me crazy
about what you just said nelson
you can notice that your sister is very
attractive
and it's not bad like it's actually a
compliment so um go ahead
yeah i don't know i don't want to know
what other things you looked up to i
just look like random things all the
time people in different states
a kangaroo can knock your ass have you
seen that kangaroo that's flexing like
this
wait kangaroos can't be the ones that
like just beat people up they know how
to box these stuff
but tell me why they square up like
somebody from oakland they was like yo
they know how to kick
bars have you seen the guy with boxing
gloves fighting a kangaroo
because she is [ __ ] up easy it's like
he got [ __ ] up it's like
tekken and you're [ __ ] joey and you
have the blue gloves oh yeah yeah
you know tekken i love that she's so
cool we like her she's cool
yeah yeah uh so this guy was sleeping
when his when the pair
i'm sorry did you have an australian
accent to
anquan i don't know how they do it um it
doesn't say if you had an
accident in the water anton anton
he uh yeah the guy just said i'm in
shock but i'm fine as long as i have my
bird
would your cats do you think your cats
would actually like wake you up oh yeah
my cats are crazy
i'm hungry no they don't even give a
[ __ ] about food they just like
they need everything to be the same
every day and like if any one thing is
off
they go they predict earthquakes when
there was an earthquake like a few weeks
ago
they like scratching it yeah they didn't
scratch the door because they're allowed
in
all the doors but they were going crazy
around the house
they're like they're going crazy they
keep meowing at me i'm like what is
wrong do we need to clean the litter box
like what's happening like they have
food they have everything
and then there was an earthquake like
two hours we needed technology that they
got because our [ __ ] wiggler sucks
that wiggler that tries to tell us man
it's too late don't tell us
during the we're missing our whiskers we
need to add the whiskers that's it
so you think those are the wigglers for
them maybe yeah
earthquake time yeah we must the problem
is i can't tell between
when there's going to be an earthquake
or when like one of the kittens in the
other room knocked over their food dish
and so like all the same reaction yeah
onyx lets me know like i know when he
has to go poop and i know when he's out
of water like he has
he does those two things uh no he
actually comes up and starts
licking me when he's like out of water
when he's out of water
and i started picking up on that i was
like oh [ __ ] you have no water in your
bowl that's why you're licking me i was
like okay and then when he has to poop
he does the same thing
but as far as like any natural disasters
i don't
know i feel like he'd be knocked out in
bed with me if there was a fire like
he's sleep we need a bird sometimes i've
had dogs that barked
all day before earthquakes really yeah
they try to run away um we didn't have
that because they were in the house
animals do like when there's earthquakes
and things like do like if they didn't
have any like cages or anything like
would they run away
and they know like they have a day's
worth of like
warning and then they get the hell out
of there it blows my mind because when
you think about what caused an
earthquake
tectonic plates like under deep deep
deep down
like hitting how the [ __ ] do they even
feel that i know
i had heard that we only see like a
certain like we actually only see a
certain percentage about like
what's going on around us and like
animals pick up on
pick up on those things do you think
they can see ghosts yeah oh
i do i do 1 000 crazy but i really do
thousand percent i watched
so when i was a kid i was like 13. i
remember
feeling this most [ __ ] up feeling i
ever felt in my whole life
it was tracking up and down my house
like we had this little walkway
and it was going like this way that way
this way that and i was like i'm just
going crazy i'm sucking myself out
and then i look down i see my dog
tricksy and she's going like this
to the wall to a wall she's going like
this
tracking a wall exactly how i was
feeling it prior to her
like to even looking at it that's pretty
crazy that's when i was like holy [ __ ]
like there's something come they can see
the spirits and we can
and as soon as i saw that by the way
yeah like cut
like that we need whiskers so i need to
grow we need whiskers
too you see when light flashes into the
eyeballs and there's like a like a
foil in the back like a copper foil
they got you've done that twice today
stop doing white eyes okay
doing it yeah this is so racist that's
the eyes of my people man stop doing
that [ __ ]
come on let's make fun of the white guys
guys seriously what the [ __ ] guys
that's our what that's how i look i'm
responsible
hey guys let's go get some hamburgers
come on guys i don't like i like
cheeseburgers mostly
[Laughter]
dicks go back to being in into your
sister
okay yeah so my sister's hot and that's
the point of that whole joke actually
is that i'm just a white guy and i'm
talking about how my sister's hot that's
the entire point but whatever
i think we're in the wrong state for
that though to make sense
definitely yeah you have to have an
overall with no shirt and then like have
like a straw in your mouth you guys are
forgetting that at least
five million republicans live in
california five million yes
so are you saying that all republicans
want to [ __ ] their sister i'm saying
it's on the menu bro
did you know there's many states that
you can marry a donkey
why because i think in the back in the
day they forgot that uh
to include bestiality into the laws
so since they overlooked it technically
it's not illegal so they're like
i'm gonna marry this fine ass and
there's all these then there's all these
laws that they enforce that they forgot
to take away
like in some states you can't walk
backwards like it's illegal to walk
why because it's what you're trying to
do why are you guys you can't feel like
an orange in a hotel room
yeah it's like something random [ __ ] has
a couple weird ass laws too
i don't know we were never allowed to
cut our hair or cut our fingernails at
night and i think it's actually illegal
to cut you that's a illegal it's not
like a house law
i have to double check but i know like
our parents put it in like we can't
whistle at night and we can't cut our
hair
wow and i think there's like some weird
should they just tell you that because
that's a that is the thing that asian
people is it an asian thing
let me tell you oh you can't whistle at
night that's one yeah but
i feel like growing up hawaiian is like
such a blend of
asian like asian cultures that i have no
idea what you don't know what's actual
law
you're like can i actually jaywalk or is
that what i never learned was that
cultural
i never learned how to whistle because
we were never allowed to will
just to be safe they said that it would
wake up the spirits if we whistled at
night so we never learned how to whistle
i never learned how to
the time of the year uh i'm cool with
what did you say
it depends on the time of the year got
it jesus i'm cool i'm cool
daylight savings time like no like
halloween here
uh no but i'm cool with the anti don't
walk backwards
law because have you been to trader
joe's everyone's walking into you
backwards
oh oh oh i forgot that i'm like oh like
oh you can't [ __ ] figure out where
you are like [ __ ] you
what's this is that considered backwards
or forwards that's definitely backwards
definitely backwards but they're not
they're gliding though so is it a walk
it's not a walk
it's a moon walk yeah it's a moonwalk
it's different what defines
walking right oh my god this [ __ ]
lawyery chick
joe this is a huge warning sign bro
where are the pitches
[Applause]
appreciate how hot she is he says he's
tempted
i didn't even say i was he's married he
would never [ __ ] love
the defense i can't be the jump to
conclusions what do you think alessandra
d'addario's brother does you think he's
goes out my sister's dump truck
no he's like my sister's hot as [ __ ] and
i understand that and
i just got to live with it i don't know
who that is no alexandra to dario do you
know who that is no
okay she's an actress an actress why did
you pull her out of everybody because
she's a youtuber as well and i just
thought people would understand that
reference oh that's up for everybody i
don't know who that is
uh she was in the newest baywatch yes
that one right yes yeah yeah
wait there's a new one the one the rock
with uh oh
that one my reference is she's a modern
day babe and that's it
okay yeah yeah and then her brother
would probably think she's brother's
probably busting to her all day or
something
i mean it is a popular pornhub job hot
chicks dude
[Music]
my